dead spin is what happens when
journalism becomes too cowardly to
confront the woke when it enters your
industry Sports journalism has been
plagued by this I mean look at some of
the great the institutions ESPN Sports
Illustrated they're now all woke zombies
because they let it in they let it take
over because they were scared instead of
saying to the woke get lost they open
the doors and now you have this this
kind of crap which by the way it's so
obviously like wrong I'm assuming they
must have done it anyway because they
knew that because dead dead spin is
dying that this might be the only way
that they can get clicks is by actually
embarrassing themselves but there is an
assumption that as long as you you know
on the woke side of the political field
uh no one's going to bother to check
because the media is on your side so
even if you mis report no one's really
going to call you out in this case uh uh
you know they did because X which is you
know why the left hates Elon Musk now
has community community notes so the
community notes called this out before
it was Amplified to the world right this
guy should have said he should have said
you know he may not be wearing black
face but somewhere someone
is and we're just raising awareness of
half black face this is the new thing
half blackace why not just say wols
sorry and send the kid you know a
pizza just a pizza I think they should
send him a lot more than a pizza because
this guy's got a lawsuit and I think the
Judge could attest to it he might not
have to save for college yeah if and
please make me understand this Jessica
because the left is very confusing if
children can choose their own gender
they can't choose what they wear to the
game I mean if the boy can wear a dress
why can't he wear a
headdress why can't he just say this was
makeup because they said boys can wear
makeup he can we have to get approval
from the left about what kind of makeup
why are you going after they can wear or
he could wear what I don't understand is
this so we beat the Native Americans in
battle right we also beat the British we
beat the British so can't we dress up as
the British also you could I can't dress
up as your
husband I can't dress up as King George
I can't dress up as a coat Dan it we
have the Patriots we have the Pirates we
have the Cowboys we have lots of mascots
that are great warriors that people
dress up as all the time and how do you
know this guy wasn't a Raiders and a
Chiefs fan this wasn't at Arrowhead
Stadium this was in Las Vegas this could
have been half Raiders fan half Chiefs
fan no one knows and so this guy only
sees one image where's his editor you
know because we're always told on the
internet you know this is why social
media this is why you need editors this
guy is an editor no one even cleared
that this is so dumb I hope he sues him
like Nick salmon for a quarter million
dollars and we're eting him on tonight
at 8 o00 Jess I would love to see that
Jessica since your name was invoked
would you like to reply before the judge
tells us about what could happen here I
I'm just kind of surprised we had this
nice break from each other Thanksgiving
holiday and you come back we to go as if
I think that this
has any legitimacy one at all it's cuz
he has rabies oh I have not come back
yet Greg if he's getting a shot though
he's doing it on air and we'll all get
to see his stomach no you get him in the
arm why why did the dog bite you with
question Democrat
owner do not slander Democratic dogs or
Democratic owners so first of all you
kept saying this guy it's not a guy it's
a child mhm like how old is that kid 10
years old maybe maybe I thought when I
first saw I thought it was seven but I'm
not I don't have good perception of how
old children are that could be a
problem I am not a pedophile just a
Democrat okay so quote of the Year y so
and you say why can't he do this the
Kansas City Chiefs themselves decided in
2020 that they didn't want people
wearing the headdresses to the games
that's their prerogative It's a private
organization I don't think that it
really matters I think that this story
is in anything I think Greg is right
that there's no censors on this this is
something that you wouldn't expect I
mean this is a storied brand that has
gone significantly downhill um in terms
of dead spin um and I think it's part of
why it wasn't picked up everywhere maybe
the community notes really did everyone
a big favor that they saw that right
away that this wasn't a thing but who
would have an expectation anyway that a
7 to 10 year-old would do blackface
right that that would be something that
would be on his mind racist parents yes
racism I would like to know who they are
Jessica judge tell us what could happen
here well there are a couple of things I
want to say number one I think it's
interesting that the guy who wrote it
his name is Karen it's Corone Phillips
but he's a Karen uh he's nothing more
than a troublemaker who was purposely
deceiving what is a young kid having a
good time at a football game I don't
think this kid is more than nine to me I
thought maybe he's seven maybe he's
eight maybe he's nine to put the burden
of racism and everything else on this
kid is an outrage an outrage that goes
so far in on my spectrum that as far as
I'm concerned it's the defamation
spectrum and I think that his parents
should consider suing because make no
mistake that kid knows that his photo is
in newspapers that we're talking about
it on you know we're the the biggest
watch show on all news cable um he's got
to get some some reward and some damage
for this now look that no one can
seriously argue this kid was just having
a good time there isn't a negative
thought on this kid's mind but what I
want to know is where's the NFL where
are the Kansas City Chiefs you know what
I want I want momes I want Kelsey I want
them to say you know what you come in
we're going to give you season tickets
we love you and stop with this nonsense
with a headdress and all that I'm tired
of political correctness I'm tired of
people saying what I can and cannot do
unless it is offensive realistically
objectively offensive the Native
American group there is a Native
American group that means the American
Indians who are demanding that the the
commanders now reinstate the name
to the Washington
football team this nonsense has got to
end it will never end it will never end
but maybe Taylor Swift could give him
tickets to the next concert why do we
have well let's throw those in as well
do we have to bring her
into
hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now